I tell them I am the dragon lady do not
mess with me I'm Kissin and this is a
show for you if you're bored of watching
people on the internet having arguments
over something they know nothing about
and trigonometry we don't pretend to be
the experts we ask the experts are
fantastic expert guests this week is a
headmistress of the Michaela free school
here in London Katherine verbal sing
welcome to trigonometry thanks for
having me it's so good to have you here
we know everything about you we've seen
the gray interview did with Dave Rubin
and others but wow that's a good start
to the interview but for anyone who
doesn't know who you are tell us a
little bit about your story through life
how are you where you are and what words
will bring you to the seat in which you
currently sit okay well Katherine
purposing is my name I'm headmistress of
Mikaela community school which is a
school in Brent Wembley Park we opened
in 2014 we now have 600 pupils and this
year is the year we get our GCSE results
so it's really exciting I suppose people
are interested or you are interested in
talking to me because I'm a bit
controversial and the things that I say
about education the stuff I say I think
it's pretty much common sense but others
find it controversial I think teachers
should stand in front of the class and
teach that is controversial and I came
to prominence I suppose in 2010 when I
gave a speech at the Conservative Party
conference a teacher at the Conservative
Party conference well I have to say I
didn't really know much about political
conferences anywhere I went along and I
gave this speech but it was also what I
said in the speech I was kind of
condemning the state of State Education
and saying how lots needed to change and
I now I'm trying to do and enact that at
school and we Michaela so all of my
teachers my senior team we all sing
the same hymn sheet we really believe
the same sorts of things and we now get
visitors I don't know we get seven to
ten visitors every day they're all
teachers tend to be from across the
country and across the world who come to
see what we do so it's been really
powerful in terms of putting the
argument forward because teachers have
been able to to see the the arguments in
theory in real life and and to see
whether or not they work and I think
they do and I always say to everybody
you're very welcome to come and visit
anytime our doors are open all the time
and people come every day and they have
lunch with the children they have a tour
and they're able to judge for themselves
well we look forward to coming you
invited us very kind of we'll check it
out but let's get into some of the stuff
that you do you've been described as
Britain's strictest headmistress well I
think they were trying to sell the
newspaper at the time yeah I think when
people talk about being strict people
imagine this kind of ogre standing over
children and it all being really mean
and nasty when in fact the number one
thing that everyone says when they come
to the school is the children are so
happy it's just a really happy place and
the reason why they're happy is
precisely because it's ordered and
structured
it's when you have chaos that children
are miserable and unhappy because
children look to us to guide them there
it's our duty to show them the way and
to allow the shy ones to shine in Emma
Caleb one of the things the visit they
look in the classrooms and they say it's
incredible the kids have their hands up
and that's because no one at Michaela
feels intimidated you can find in
classrooms that not with us but
elsewhere you if a child puts their hand
up are they gonna get bullied for
putting their hand up are they gonna be
laughed at oh you you're just the
teacher's pet you're the nerd you know
what I mean I was that one always I was
the nerd with my hand up right exactly
so you know from your own experiences at
school what that was like that doesn't
happen
Michaela learning is really admired and
and if you're able to answer that's
great that means you've been listening
and so you'll find 75% of hands in the
class will go up and that's what I mean
about having the order in the structure
if you have order everyone's able to
listen if the teacher is standing at the
front of the class there
they can look in one direction to see
the teacher if the teacher is teaching
in the way that we would consider to be
excellent teaching the children have a
chance to really grapple with with the
subject and then be able to put their
hands up and answer questions and then
feel successful and then their
self-esteem goes through the roof but um
we do things the other way around in
that sense so you might find more modern
methods of teaching or trying to address
their self-esteem we don't address their
self-esteem we think about the learning
we make sure they learn and guess what
their self-esteem then benefits because
they're learning because it's very
interesting that you say excellent
teaching because I've been I was a
teacher for ten years in primary and
secondary and the idea of what good
teaching is seemed to change year upon
year upon year because education is a
political football in the UK so what do
you think is excellent teaching for you
yeah and it's really good point things
do change all the time and to a certain
extent there is some value in change
because people you don't want to just be
stuck in the same way so we change our
minds all the time one of the things
that people think is oh well that
Michaela they just have one way of doing
things well that's just not true
we have changed our mind over the years
and we also change our minds daily about
things so change isn't necessarily bad
but some of the ideas I would say I've
been bad over the last 50 years in
education so what has changed for the
worse is that education has become more
child centered and what I mean by that
is rather than the teacher leading the
learning it's the child that's leading
the learning and that comes from the
idea that learning should always be
personalized and that each child is his
own self to be able to just discover
what he wants I want to be a dancer I
want to be an artist I want to be a you
know I want to work with computers and
that's fine the idea of wanting to do
what you want but the teacher needs
who's the history teacher needs to teach
the history and the child needs to learn
from the teacher who knows more than
them that concept has been lost and the
people who aren't in teaching that seems
really odd well obviously the history
teacher knows more about history but
you'd be amazed by the number of
teachers who say things like I learned
just as much for my children as as the
children learn from
and I always think well okay
then you must not be a very good teacher
and something's wrong there and I'm not
saying that the children can't point out
little quirky things and they don't make
you laugh and I love working for
children with children for that reason
but buzz the teacher ought to know more
the teacher ought to stand at the front
of the class the death should be in rows
the children should look to the teacher
I always say the teacher is driving the
bus right and the teacher drives the bus
because children can't drive and the cat
the cat drive right I mean the thing is
in teaching people don't think that they
think no no no no no children should
just do they should be in groups and
they should be looking at each other so
the teacher then moves around the desks
as a facilitator of learning as opposed
to no I'm the teacher I'm driving the
bus forward and all the children that
can jump on the bus with me and then a
really excellent teacher is making sure
that children don't jump off on unroot
you're on your way to Rome you don't
want them jumping off at Paris you don't
want some of them never leaving home you
want to make sure that you are so
skilled as a teacher that every time oh
you're looking out the window you jumped
off the bus Bing little Johnny come back
in Oh you're doodling you jumped off the
bus okay get back in and you keep going
keep going until you get to Rome and you
are a brilliant teacher if you've
managed to get to Rome and all the kids
are still with you so where's your
really controversial I haven't heard
anything controversial so far what what
that is reversal about that is really
controversial really controversial well
the teacher standing in front of a class
and being the leader in that in that pro
that's controversial yeah because III
think it's because too many people in
teaching and actually in society
nowadays have a problem with authority
they think that if you are in authority
you are also its authoritarian and
that's not true in fact if you're not in
authority with children then the
children take control the children are
the ones who run that class and then the
teacher is just running around and up
please please do some work silence
everyone silence as they say you know
you stand up in front of the class ten
minutes silence and anyone who's been in
teaching will know what I'm talking
about
and that's because the children are
running that class and in fact the idea
of children running things is perfectly
acceptable in in in schools I mean they
have student panels for instance where
the students are deciding when a deputy
head comes for an interview the students
are deciding whether or not the deputy
head should be hired I mean now really
yeah yeah that's that's common yeah it's
perfect now they're not the only ones
deciding I look at my face guys you know
you're not the only they're not the only
ones deciding but depending on the
school they will give a certain amount
of weight to what the children want and
that that's mad as far as I'm concerned
there are lots of things that you where
you want to listen to them so we have a
year 11 committee for the ball the year
11 ball when they leave and they're
telling us where they want to go which
hotel to rent all that kind of stuff
great they ought to be participating in
that we've got future leaders in the
school who take our guests around and
give them tours and they feedback to us
about the school and so on yes you know
are the toilets working I do you have
enough basketball hoops in the yard and
all that sort of thing we need their
point of view but do they know who makes
a good deputy head do they know what
makes a good teacher of course not but
that is very common in schools that's
just one example the idea that the
teacher should be the authority is
controversial because they jump to the
idea that they then must be
authoritarianism mean and they they're
oppressive so people often come to the
school thinking well it must be an
oppressive place where children are
miserable because the teachers are in
charge literally but that's exactly the
opposite is what you find children are
thrilled because they're being led by
their teachers which is what they want I
always say children push we push back
they expect you to give them a detention
if they misbehave if you don't then you
are letting them down it's very
interesting you say that because
especially when you work with kids who
come from really difficult backgrounds
where there's not a lot of stability to
them
is a one stable influence in their life
where they're going to go in they're
going to be able to sit the same place
the same thing is going to happen every
day they're going to get fed and to them
that is their safe place and if you go
in and you have this attitude of you
know the church child takes control like
you said to a child especially a young
child days terrifying yeah that's
exactly right and and it's not even just
the shy children or the awkward children
who are then eaten alive in that kind of
system but children who wouldn't have
been bullies become bullies because they
have to to survive right you know
there's that film wonder which was based
on the book but but but this is a boy
who's had lots of operations on his face
and he goes he goes back to school Julie
in the in the trailer you see Julia
Roberts and the husband I can't remember
it's one of the big American actors and
they they go to the school gates and as
I say he's disfigured and they send him
off and she hangs on to her husband and
says please God let them be kind to him
you know and the whole book is based on
can a boy who looks like this survived
at school because it's going to be a
nightmare for him that would never
happen at Mikayla
I just wouldn't happen in fact we had a
girl who was disfigured in various ways
I mean she also had she was severely Sen
and in her in the end her mother decided
to send her to a special school but not
because she was unhappy with Mikayla but
because it was closer to their house and
she got a place there but um the girl
was crying when she was leaving saying
she was gonna miss all her friends and
she loved it and everybody was kind to
her and nice to her there was no
bullying at all and so um I often think
that book simply wouldn't exist if all
schools were like Mikayla Hawaiian oh
sorry I'm Francis no I was going to say
just touching on the bullying element of
it one of the things that I noticed
throughout my career and the things that
I found actually quite distressing was
the way bullying changed in
metamorphosize especially when it came
to social media bullying on social media
and that I personally think social media
is not one of most damaging influences
on our young children especially on
girls then it is on boys because the
amount of bullying horrendous the
messages that I used to see which I
found upsetting and they weren't even
directed at me yeah yeah so we have a
major user at school about social media
so that's the one place so bullying in
the school doesn't happen but it will
happen in social media and but what's
great is that you can not be involved in
that if you don't have a smartphone
right and we have a huge push we have we
give digital detox events to the parents
where parents are invited and I talked
them through the dangers of social media
and the smartphones my advice to all
parents is do not give your child a
smartphone not until they're 16 possibly
even 18 and that again is controversial
people think but why would you do that
children free they should be able to do
what they like well you can do that
there was one young man not at our
school who was it with with tech posting
certain things on YouTube insulted a
South London gang he was knifed to death
there are other children I could tell
you about who they get involved in
criminal activity they get involved in
gang activity because they meet these
people through unsupervised access to
the Internet and that's what the
smartphone gives you unsupervised access
to the Internet and we want we once used
to put the porn magazines on the top
shelf in the shops nowadays well you
give yourself give me child smartphone
they can access porn they can access
gambling they can do anything they like
on there and parents are a lot less
tech-savvy than are their their children
and so children are running rings around
their parents my big advice is do not
give them a smart phone if you do the
iPhone for instance has all sorts of
controls on there where you could put a
password and you can block certain sites
snapchat Instagram whatsapp they are
toxic you need to get off there when you
look at what the way in which children
will talk to each other the bullying
that goes on the swearing that the it's
just it's absolutely dreadful not to
mention the way in which they will use
technology just to take pictures of each
other's homework and never really do
their work you are undermining your
child massively if you give them a
smartphone it's really really
interesting that you say that because
you know like we were talking about with
the bullying element of it and the gangs
how be the problem is gangs at the
moment in London because the average
person picks up their copy of the
Evening Standard and they will see you
know another boy stabbed to death
tragic where do you see the gang
in London how bad is it and is it worse
and we actually think is I don't know if
it's worse I mean of course we do a very
good job I'm not the best person to talk
to in a way because our children we do
such a good job of protecting them that
they and they don't necessarily have
that the typical experience of of
children elsewhere we're persuading
parents to give up smartphones
we're persuading parents to pick them up
after school or etc etc now sometimes
you know we have issues but um I don't
know if it's worse I mean there is a
problem there's a problem there are so
many problems there are so many issues
that children come up against like you
were talking about girls for instance on
social media if you allow your child to
have a smartphone and it's a she's a
girl all she understands about her
self-worth is you've got to make
yourself look four five years older you
got to pout your lips and stick your
bottom out and make yourself look really
sexy cuz that's all you're worth
the idea of being a powerful woman one
day and running your own business or
being a lawyer or whatever it is they
that doesn't exist in that world it's
really it's it's really frightening and
what I'm always trying to get across to
parents and I do the same on Twitter and
so on is a don't fool yourself parents
they some people who argued me said I
trust my child okay you know fine I
could tell you about poor Brett Bednar
who at 14 years old was gaming with his
friends there was one boy in the gaming
ring that his mother didn't know she was
a wonderful mother you know she used to
do baby swimming with him when he was a
baby and all this um and then there was
this about the boy and over two years
he was gradually groomed you know and he
loved this boy and thought he was so
brilliant and one day this boy sending
money to get into a cab went to his
house was tied to a chair with duct tape
and had his throat slit now if his
mother had not allowed him unsupervised
access to the Internet that boy would be
alive today and what happens I could
tell you about Kaylie I could tell you
about Molly the other day who sadly
committed suicide because of all the
self-harm images she was sent by via
Instagram and via um it may been
snapchat actually I don't want to I
don't know which one it was it was one
of them and Pinterest kept on sending
these these images and even though you
try and get off these images you can't
because the algorithms are such that the
more you click on them the more they
keep sending you and parents don't know
Molly's parents didn't know and then
they say every time this happens parents
make a video they make some video about
to warn other parents they say please
listen to me
listen to what I'm saying nobody watches
these videos right so I show this to my
parents and I say you know listen you
know listen to what I'm saying you're
putting your child's life in danger now
that's the worst end of it then there's
just the point put point of well what
about their GCSEs you know so many of
them are addicted so they can't get off
their smartphone when they're working at
night and they're saying to us please
miss help me my mom isn't home because
she's working three jobs
she's she can't take the phone away from
me what do I do I'm addicted and I can't
get ready for my GCSEs it's a major
problem and I genuinely think that the
smartphone will increase the division
between the poor and the rich because
it's the rich who argue with me and who
constantly say to me on Twitter oh but
my child is firing what are you talking
about and I'm telling you because
they're at home they have the nannies
and the tutors and they're able to
monitor their child's use of social
media and what they don't understand is
that those ideas filter through
especially when journalists so I was i
spoke to Toby young recently I was
telling him off for for saying that
fortnight was ok because he writes about
these things and I said you are a
talking head and you have
responsibilities
you cannot talk about this stuff because
actually your boys probably gonna be
fine but what happens is those ideas
trickle down to my families and we at
school are struggling on the ground the
people who support me 100% on Twitter
when I say this stuff at teachers
because the teachers get it they see it
and I'm telling you in 20 years there
will be controls on these things they
will be giving out warnings just like
they do for cigarettes and alcohol and
driving and getting married and having
sex all of these things are banned to
children and I'm telling you I was just
thinking about it on the on the tube on
the way here today I was watching all
these people on their phones and I was
thinking isn't it interesting how Steve
Jobs has given this extraordinary thing
to people and he's not here to see just
how damaging it is
it's an incredible point because I
remember when I before I left my job I
was a year six teacher so for overseas
viewers and listeners that's 10 and 11
it's the last year of primary education
in this country and we used to run six
eight lessons in the last year and I had
quite a few parents coming and going I
don't want my child learning about sex I
don't want them learning about anything
and I said your kids got an iPhone 6
exactly they know more about sex than
you do exactly they don't realize that's
it people don't realize and people say
well I my anti phone and then I'm on the
Twitter on Twitter because I'm an adult
I can make decisions about how I'm gonna
spend my time of course but children are
children it's one of the biggest
mistakes we make in teaching and
generally in society these days is that
we treat children as experts we think
that children are like us they're not
they need guidance they need us to to
make decisions for them right we do like
people say to me so 10 years old
when they're looking for a school
secondary school often families will say
well you know it's up to him he he
should decide and I say so when he was 4
did you choose his primary school or did
he say so no we chose his primary school
I said so why is it any different why is
it any different you need to choose him
raised school now he's he will choose
his school according to where his
friends are going if they're a big
sports whole I mean he's not going to
think about things that matter and that
is what's keys that we need to recognize
that children are children and it is our
duty to look after them do you think
that this discomfort with authority that
you talked about is it is it a broader
issue in society because it seems to me
that it's not just education like I I'll
go play basketball in my local park and
I'll see these parents chasing their
child who is determining where they go
what they do what kind of food the
families it's all determined by a
five-year-old that's right that's right
and that's and that becomes standard and
in fact as a as a parent if you try and
take a harder line with your child your
friends look at you as if you are the
unreasonable one okay and if you're made
to feel like that then the social
pressure that you feel around you it is
to be it is to let the child leave
things and I think of course children
need to have choices about things you
know do you want
with your food or not that's fine but
what school do you want to go to I think
clearly it's the parents who should be
making that decision and it's
interesting though the points that you
raised that were fascinating I wanted to
talk to you because I wanted to get your
opinion on this we've got a crisis in
this country with teaching and teacher
retention rates people qualify they do
the pgc we spend hundreds of thousands
if not millions but getting teachers
through this system the postgraduate
certificate of education they stay what
is it maximum something like five years
they drop out of this system
what are the problems with teaching in
this country well the two big things are
behavior and workload those are the two
big things so the behavior I mean look
if you're being told to f off every day
people don't want to do that I suppose
and it takes a particular type of person
but most people don't want to be told to
F I don't want that that adrenalin
having to pump all the time because you
feel like you're going to war that
shouldn't be happening right and so
teachers will leave for those reasons
but they'll also leave because of
workload and the workload of course is
caused in part because of behavior and
it's also caused because if the teaching
methods and I keep referring to these
teaching methods if you're having to
move amongst the desks and you're doing
all of this so-called creative work
which isn't creative at all it actually
stunts learning there's then a lot of
pressure on you for the children to
achieve but the only way to make them to
achieve is to teach them properly so it
can be very confusing for a teacher when
you want me to teach this way and that's
what senior team keep telling me to do
but if you want me to get the results
then well III have to do that so I have
to teach in a traditional manner so you
move between the two not quite sure what
to do sadly people think about
traditional teaching they think it just
means rote learning and yes there are
some things you want to rote learn so
you do want to rote learn your times
tables you do want to rote lunar dates
and history but that doesn't mean your
rote learning everything you're still
having class discussions we do pair work
with the children where they discuss
turn to your partner we say and then
they discuss quickly and then we say
hands up and then they all have a bit of
a class discussion on it um they
obviously do independent work as well
where they're writing our essays and
they're analyzing
things it you don't not have analysis
when you do traditional teaching in fact
it's at the heart of traditional
teaching sadly people can interpret
traditional teaching to mean everyone's
just sat there rote learning something
and repeating stuff back to the teacher
that is certainly not the case all of
our visitors at Michaela would testify
to say obviously that is not the case at
Michaela but it's unfortunate that it
can be an interpretation of that and I
think that's why traditionalism has had
a bad name and over the last 50 years
gradually it has disappeared from our
schools and do you think it's because
parents have had a bad experience at
school with certain teachers and then
they come into school with their
prejudices intact go well I had a bad
experience at school therefore I don't
like teachers therefore I don't like the
education system so I'm not gonna want
to engage with it yeah I mean that is
certainly the case for a number of
families in the inner city and so on
you'll find that but I'm talking more
about the politicians the people with
voices out there who talk about what
works or even the teachers themselves
they are seduced so Ken Robinson for
instance who has the largest number of
views for a TED talk of all TED Talks
right I mean there's five million or
something mad I mean he says he's so
many people love him and they love him
despite the fact that 99% of what he
says is wrong it really is
I say 99% because the stuff he says on
ADHD is actually correct but the rest of
it is all wrong he mistakenly thinks
that traditional education is bad for
children when it's what teaches them and
he promotes progressive education which
is which which is about supposed
creativity and I say supposed creativity
because the only way in which you can be
creative is through gaining lots of
knowledge you cannot be creative with
your artwork unless you have been taught
the basics in drawing you cannot be
creative with your music as a musician
unless you have been taught the basics
in your instrument to be able to learn
and move forward you cannot be a
creative
French a comedian for instance because
you've learned French and you're being a
comedian in France
well you can't pull out those jokes and
be really at ease in the French language
unless you have learnt the basics from
the beginning and then moved up those
those are obvious really to anybody who
understands teaching properly
sadly Ken Robinson and the whole
progressive movement is very seductive
um they say what he says is oh I know
you had a bad time at school was because
people didn't recognize that you were
really talented underneath and you
wanted to be a dancer didn't you and if
if somebody had recognized but instead
they forced you to learn those awful
times tables when we should have ignored
those and we should have gone with your
passion and people listening adults go
but it's interesting that you know that
you talk about this because having been
a teacher for so long I agree the one
thing where I find is that more more
especially in primary is we've become
data factories well we get kids to learn
something by rote and then they
regurgitate it in a test and in a few
weeks later that knowledge is gone okay
so what you're saying there is because
they've been taught so badly in a
progressive fashion for so long all
teachers remember I said they were
confused right they're confusing on the
one hand you want me to teach in this
trendy way which isn't really teaching
but we're having fun and then on the
other hand you want me to get exams so
what happens is for years they are
taught in this trendy way facilitating
the learning let's all write on sugar
paper I'm gonna stick things up on the
wall and you're all gonna get off and
you're gonna find them I'm gonna
blindfold one of you it's all gonna be
fun and it is fun it is fun if the
children are learning about that much
content and then what happens is you get
closer to the exams whether it's the
year six SATs or it's the GCSEs at 16
the teachers will go we've got to do
something
we got a rote learn a lot of stuff
because you're gonna get it we gotta get
through this exam and so that's week so
that is when you bring in the boom boom
boom we got to do it got to do it and
then people say ah you see there's too
much traditional Road learning in the
classrooms but actually how'd they way
back at the beginning of year seven or
way back at the beginning of year one
but in doing the rote learning of
timetables have been doing the rote
learning of phonics and so on if they
had learned that stuff properly and
really built on the basics so you're
always building on the basics building a
little bit more a bit a little bit more
then by the time they get there to those
exams see you're not teaching towards
the exams anymore you're just the exam
is there but you know so much so you
know this much stuff and you get
examined on that but what ends up
happening in schools because they
haven't really been taught properly for
so long you were then gosh we've got to
get through this exam so let's just rote
learn and get through that exam and then
that's all they're really taught
properly that's what ends up happening
that that's where the confusion is so
Katherine explained this to me then
there's someone who doesn't know
anything about education none of what
you're saying sounds controversial to me
at all
right and given you know I've seen
videos from your school about how the
kids behave and will as I said will look
forward to coming and seeing it live but
it seems like a great thing that you've
created right so why why people calling
you a Nazi why why why all this stuff
obviously I do look like yeah
because as I say the authority and the
authoritarian thing then we have lots of
small C conservative values at the
school and people don't like those
values even the word you know small C
conservative makes people go you know
and what are those values things like
our belief in personal responsibility
children are responsible for themselves
if you don't get your homework done well
then that is your responsibility often
in the more progressive world they they
will want to say well it's not his fault
he has a difficult home background his
his brother was beaten up last night he
has a long journey to school whatever
the reason is there's always excuses
that are made for children especially
children who are poor who have difficult
backgrounds and so that's why he
misbehaved dr. Maltz cuz he's having a
difficult home life that's why he's
beating up his friends in the yard you
know I often think I don't see why the
two are even connected and they're not
connected at all but the excuse making
mechanism just goes into play
automatically in schools
so that's personal responsibility we
believe in duty and obligation so what I
mean by that is we have a duty you
notice that I kept saying we we have a
duty to children as adults in the school
system we have a duty to educate
children properly the word Duty often is
just disappeared from our language that
we so children have a duty to each other
I have a duty to behave not just because
I want to make sure I'm staying my
lesson but because I don't want to
disrupt for everyone else I have a duty
to be kind to my to my fellow classmates
because that that's just that's put upon
me by the world you know I I believe in
the whole and the team and I am a team
player as opposed to it's all about me
so that's something we believe another
thing that we believe we believe that
there should be some relation between
effort and reward so what I mean by that
is in the progressive world everybody
gets a prize so almost surprising right
everybody get surprised because they
feel sad for the ones who don't get the
prize and it comes from a good place
they're thinking which is that oh what
about poor little Johnny who is a nice
kid and we don't want him to lose out we
don't want to feel bad so we're gonna
make sure everybody gets a certificate
problem with that is that it stops
everyone from from working hard and from
trying to achieve and our big motto is
work hard be kind right we want them to
work hard and one of the things that
motivates children to work hard is to
know well I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
rewarded for this and somebody else
hasn't got rewarded for that because
I've done the work for it so we believe
there ought to be some kind of
relationship between effort and reward
whereas others more progressive people
will think that that's just mean you're
being mean to little Johnny so we think
they're being mean to little Johnny
because johnny is gonna stop working
because it doesn't matter everybody gets
not only will Johnny stop working
but you know little David who find who
does work hard will also stop working
cuz he thinks well I'm the same as
Johnny so who cares and then it all goes
out the window
more horrifies me about just that
particular thing is there is a real
world out there Catherine isn't there
where these kids are gonna go out into
and they're gonna very quickly find out
that you don't get a prize for being you
you get a prize for working hard for
achieving for creating that's where you
get rewarded for that's right that's
right
that's right I don't know I mean this is
people in the world where they they do
this they do think they're helping the
children I always say sadly with many of
these so-called virtues that contradict
the ones that I'm talking about
it's ranaut really about the children
it's about the people who are who are
doing this feeling good about themselves
they want to be able to sit at a dinner
party and say I'm a nice person I feel
really good you know and they they want
in the moment of course it's not nice
handing out a detention nobody likes
that and they the progressives who
accuse us they like to paint this
picture of they are statistic and they
love hurting children and they want to
stand over them and make them be quiet
and then say ha you're in detention but
actually the reality is what will happen
in the lesson is the teacher will say
now you know Johnny turned around that
that's a demerit now it's a warning
essentially Johnny you've turned around
that's a demerit I need to make sure
we're focused and then when Johnny turns
around again the teacher will say Johnny
come on he'd leave me with no choice
here I've got to give you the tension
Johnny says here are you right you know
I did I did turn around again I've got
the detention what'd he do he does a
30-minute detention he does some work in
that detention great I mean he's
actually benefited in some way um but if
people continually see that as the
teacher somehow getting pleasure out of
giving the detention as opposed to doing
their job and doing their duty right
it's our duty to make sure that we give
them order and what I always say
is that you you cannot run a school on
detentions you just can't do it right
like you put on all these detentions
there's 600 about them and there's like
50 60 odd of us I mean you know then
they are just rebelling you need the
tipping point right you need the
majority of them to be with you the 10%
on the edges are kept in line with the
tension but you need 85 90 percent of
them to get what you're doing and
understand it and love it and so they
get a detention they go you know what
but I get a great education so I don't
care I'll sit my thirty minutes
detention but I know I'm gonna come out
brilliant out of this school whereas if
I was elsewhere I wouldn't
education now you talk about the 10% on
the edges and I agree with you but what
about the 0.5% don't respond to
detention don't respond in the kids that
we've all dealt with who you can't seem
to get through the ones who go to the
PRU so those are the pupil referral unit
so then we're which when a kid can no
longer be attending mainstream school
what do we do with those kids because
there's a problem with expulsion rates
and then those kids getting involved in
gangs yeah and again what I would say is
that wrongly schools that are like ours
are accused of filling out the proves
when it's exactly the opposite it's the
schools that are chaotic that are
constantly having to expel kids because
there's chaos you have far fewer kids
leaving the schools with order because
those kids the kids who are bad but not
that bad don't ever become that bad
because of the order that keeps them in
in line right it's it's it's the schools
that have total chaos they're decent
kids become worse and worse remember I
said earlier about um you end up having
to become a bully in order to survive
because your reputation matters you know
and you have to be super cool you see
that in like Greece for instance but you
know and it's not you it's it's still
like nice you know white middle-class
kids in Greece where is obviously when
you're in the inner city it becomes a
lot more you know when he's saying I
have a rep to protect and all that kind
of thing and you want to be a t-bird and
you want to be super cool and you want
to not be in lessons you know that kind
of behavior it's because the t-birds are
in control they're running things that
happens far less in a school with order
but yes I mean there has to be pros and
and and if a child gets excluded they
need to go there although I have to say
children never stay permanently in a
prove what 10 what always happens is
that their move to another secondary
school to give them another star so
people outside of Education think oh my
goodness ISM is terrible well actually
they go there and the ideas will they go
to that Pru and then they'll go to a
different secondary school and hopefully
have a better start the problem is is
that if the secondary school that they
go to is chaotic then they just go back
to being a chaotic kid right well you
know I was thinking when you talk about
discipline and
how you kind of keep that 10% in line I
probably would have been when I was a
kid at school I was quite rebellious
what I was found is I kind of like you
say always knew where the line was
exactly and and so if I was called out
and properly appropriately punished for
a misdemeanor of some kind yes that
restricted me from becoming more
rebellious exactly I kept me very much
in exactly that's exactly right so what
I always say is you don't see the kids
taking their clothes off and running
around the car doors naked do you
because they know that that's just like
completely unacceptable they just don't
do it right that could do it I mean the
code but they don't know it mystic boy -
okay so there is the extreme yeah but in
all your years of teaching you have one
example in my 25 years of teaching I
don't know I mean like I've never seen
that so the fact is that there are
certain things the children will not do
right and that's because the school it's
just obvious you don't do that
so at Mikayla it's obvious that you
wouldn't walk away from your teacher if
your teacher was talking to you often
teachers come and they say what'd you do
when the kid just gets up and walks out
of the lesson we're like wow I don't
know we that doesn't really happen here
yeah well what do you do when when the
child just swears at you and marches off
well it doesn't really happen at Mikayla
right the point is that it's what you
said the children will will go to the
boundary they know how to play the game
they know how far they can push it and
the cool ones will push it that far
because they're saying to everybody look
at me so you know what our kids do it's
really funny in the in in our silent cuz
we have silent corridors again people
say oh my goodness it's so impressive
well they happily move very quickly from
one lesson to the other as opposed to
having their heads bashed in which is
what happens when in schools with
challenging intakes I understand that
the schools without challenging intakes
you don't need this so it depends on the
level what kind of intake you have but
our kids move along happily in silence
and because they're in silence their way
of rebelling is to go and then some
people come to me said we've got an
issue Catherine we're hearing
I always laughing isn't it great but
that's what they've had to do that yeah
that's and that's where my staff are
going oh my goodness
we've got issues you know and and I
laughs I think it's hilarious
so what do you do at the school you have
the you have the boot camp what'd you do
before which is kind of teaching you
guys how to behave that's really key
you have the silent corridors like talk
us through the system yeah
boot camp is really important because
the thing is you can have all these
rules but you must support the children
in achieving the rules you can't just
say right you've got detentions got
detentions to get your 85% 90% of kids
to really buy in and to be honest I
think we go out a hundred percent even
the even the naughtiest kids in the
school they'll all say to you yeah but
you know what at least I learn here you
know they'll all say that but they're
still on me being kept in line because
they've got detentions where is the
eighty ninety nine ninety percent
they're there they're really bought in
they really get it and when you talk to
the kids come and have lunch you'll see
you'll be on mixed tables and you'll see
them all saying yeah yeah yeah we do get
detentions but we really like it we like
yeah they leave and thank the teachers
for giving them essentials they will
actually do that and people say oh
that's really weird well yeah but they
are kids understand it's through
detentions that having those detentions
managed to keep manages to keep order
now why do they get it we spend six days
at the beginning of every September the
rest of school doesn't come back we only
have the Year sevens arrive and we teach
them how to behave in the Michaela way
so it's unfair to expect behaviors of
children where you haven't taught them
how to do it
we also heavily support them so we
expect them to bring certain equipment
every day we have an equipment shop
that's open every morning in the school
the kids run it right so you can turn up
in the morning with your ten P and buy a
pen and then you don't get into trouble
you don't get a detention for not having
one so you have got to have the support
mechanisms around them in order to
enable them to meet the standards that
you want and as long as you do that your
children will meet those standards and
do you ever have an issue with parents
which is what I sometimes used to have
and I know a lot of teachers have well
you kidding give a kid a detention and
the parent comes in and goes why have
you given where have you given my child
at detention you know how dare you bla
bla bla bla bla I've heard my child's
version of events they said it was exes
fault yeah I mean sometimes although I
have to say it's quite rare with us and
that's because at the beginning
and they join the school I tell them I
am the dragon lady do not mess with me
and I'm really I say it like that I say
to them the day I send my child to your
school I will do what you say you are
now sending your child to me and he's
mine and I'm very sent I'm very very
serious about that so they get it they
get it and they just kind of think you
know when it comes to me and that's
quite good because I want to have this
kind of Wizard of Oz effect you know and
so they don't really do that as much I
mean now and again they do but generally
speaking they get it not only that but
obviously if the kids are getting a
great education and the parents know it
they then just accept it they to go you
know what I'm really annoyed about the
fact we got that attention but this
school is really good and he has learned
his times disables and you didn't know
them all way through primary school and
now he knows them so actually I'm just
this is the I'm just gonna put up with I
[Music]
want to move a little bit onto the
political side of this because there's
something that you've talked about in
the past and and just where the
opposition to what you're doing comes
from because you know if everything what
you're saying is true which it is right
then you would want every school in the
country to be like that wouldn't you
yeah and yet it seems to be that you're
getting a lot of pushback rather than
you know people coming in and going oh
yeah we need to transform the education
system along these lines yeah that's
right why is that uh well I suppose the
same idea you know there anti-authority
there auntie responsibilities for kids
they want them to be want to make
excuses for them so all of those
standard issues oh it's racism that
stopped me from having the life I wanted
it's sexism it's it's because I came
from a single-parent families because I
grew up on that estate they're always
these reasons and you know what I'm not
saying that none of that stuff is true
right but the fact of the matter is that
if you don't take responsibility
yourself and say okay you know what
there's racism in the world but I'm
gonna negotiate my way around it because
I have to because otherwise what I'm
gonna do sell my deathbed and say well I
could have had this great life but you
know I was black so here you go I mean
what kind of madness is that and what
people don't seem to understand it so
you keep telling a black child well the
world is racist you can't possibly ever
succeed he gives up right you have got
to have a can-do mentality you know and
it's the business about wanting to sit
around the dinner table and feel good
about yourself I think a lot of people
in positions of power and influence like
to feel that they are the knights in
shining armor who are swooping in to
save the poor children and they swoop in
with all the wrong ideas and they ruin
these children right they have blood on
their hands as far as a monster and they
really do some of these people
politicians who who just push all the
wrong ideas and ruin these children's
chances in life but then they get to sit
around at dinner parties and say oh but
aren't I wonderful look at me I've just
you know standards is easy you know we
need to just get more money just give
more money and I'm not gonna say no to
more money I love more money in school
but um III wish somebody was talking
about in positions of power I wish
somebody was talking about the right
kinds of ideas and sadly often the
people who are talking about more money
are also pushing the wrong ideas and and
that's that is upsetting for me because
I have known thousands tens of thousands
of children in my lifetime who I think
have been failed by the system and and
and we could have we spent 90 billion a
year on education more than some
countries in Eastern Europe who will
beat us in Pisa like Lithuania there are
various countries in Eastern Europe who
beat us in in the international tests
and they spend a 20 percent what we
spend on on our education system and I
say say I want more money so I'm not
saying I don't want more money but over
the labor years recently they doubled
the expense on the education system and
results of flatlined so it is not about
spending more money it is about it's
about the ideas in the education system
but what I'm really happy about is that
people are coming they come every day to
our school people are changing I do feel
like we are winning I do I mean I
look it's a very slow win and I feel
like it I'll be doing this for the next
50 years you know and to be honest I'm
not sure that the real change will come
in my lifetime but you as a you know as
an individual we all have a duty to
contribute to society and to make the
world a better place and and when I get
to my deathbed I will hand the baton on
to someone else well it's interesting
that he said because not to compare what
we do with obviously the great work that
you do but we feel like the reason we
started the show is we wanted to start
to have some of the more honest
conversations about different topics and
the pushback we've had is exactly the
pushback that you've had and you know I
understand from particular what Francis
tells me that the the kind of the
teaching world is very left-wing and
dominated by that strain of thinking the
same with comedy you know and we're now
finding that we're being ostracized in
our world and we're Nazis and we're
right-wing and all this crazy stuff and
it's just amazing to me like with us
that we were talking earlier before we
started the show about how you know we
just talk right at the end they were
just comedians or we're just doing the
show but you actually have results to
prove the the merit of what you're doing
and somehow people are still able to
ignore you ignore that to criticize that
that's what doesn't make sense to me
well of course those most of those
people haven't been at school mmm right
so they make stuff up about school and
they say how miserable it is and so on
they have no idea but why why would they
do that because they need to feel good
about themselves at the dinner party I
mean it really is about and they're
ideologues I mean they refused to change
their minds I mean the irony is they say
we don't change our minds I mean I am
somebody who has completely changed my
mind over the years you know I used to
be a progressive teacher I I would try
out these methods in my classroom and I
think well they don't really work and so
over the years I have developed my ideas
about things and I'm constantly
developing them now six months ago or a
year ago you never heard me talk about
social media at all and the reason was
because we only had the little ones at
school we've now got year seven through
to eleven so we've got up to sixteen
year olds and it's only become really
apparent to me in the last six months or
so just how dangerous social media is
and so I've now started my whole
campaign about that and we've got
digital drop-off and digital detox
happening it's
I didn't explain digital drop-off where
the kids they can drop off their phones
at school from Monday to Friday for
instance and have a bit of a break so
that their brains can start working
again um I never did that before
there's a big change in my thinking
there are so many massive changes the
the turn to your partner stuff we didn't
used to do until maybe a year and a half
two years ago
Ruth Miskin who is um she does the
readwrite ink phonics for schools and
she's incredible woman she came to visit
so she was a guest right a guest visited
the school and said I really like it
Katherine but I wish she'd do more turn
to your partner I said what we do do it
because we did do it then and um and I
said well she said yeah well you know
you don't go very often and I said well
how often would you want to see it in a
lesson and and I said we'd probably do
it about five or six times and she said
well Katherine actually haven't expect
to see it maybe 25 30 times and yeah so
and the reason so she explained and the
reason is you know your instead of cold
calling the kids cold calling meaning
you're just asking the kids give an
answer and and they give the answer cold
right you you do you do warm calling and
warm calling you do the to turn to your
partner first so you kind of practiced
your answer with your friend and you
you've checked is it right yeah I think
so okay and then you put your hand up
afterwards you are more likely to feel
confident in answering than you would do
if you were cold cold um she explained
all of that to me and so on so I said
you know what let's try this so we
started doing it more and more and it
really it was fantastic
so now we do it across the school and
it's really great now that was a guest
who visited let alone what my teachers
say to me and say you know Katherine
this isn't working let's try and do this
and then I talked about it with my
senior team and we say okay everybody
and I stand up on briefing on Monday
morning and I say we're gonna try this
way now we're gonna try that way we are
constantly changing our minds when I
took to head teachers I always say the
thing that you need to do as a head
teacher is constantly be questioning
what you're doing and thinking am I
doing this because that's what's always
been done or am i doing this because
this is what works and I think sadly in
education there's far too much of doing
stuff because that's what's what's
always been done I think it's really
exciting time in education it's really
exciting because people are
are coming - they're starting to change
their minds 15 years ago the
conversation between knowledge and
skills and traditionalism and
progressivism just didn't exist before
Michael Gove it didn't exist Michael
Gove changed changed the game in
education big time and free schools
changed the game in education because
coupled with him doing the political
stuff free schools then like ours for
instance a few of them have done things
differently on the ground and and other
teachers now are able to benefit from
from seeing that I mean we had an event
last night there were all these
languages teachers my languages
Department ran it about the kinds of
methods that they use in their classroom
and all these teachers came and could
look and see and learn from us and and
could privately say to me I really like
what you're saying on Twitter but I
would never say that annoys me is when
somebody who is not white comes out
espouses a conservative value whatever
it may be and they're accused of being a
traitor to their own race or having
internalized racism all this kind of
stuff have you experienced that have you
had people accuse you of that yes yes um
definitely I mean it is interesting
because I often wonder why on the whole
I don't wonder but I I think I think
about the fact that the black left often
leave me alone
they do so they'll attack Schrom Bailey
or they'll attack
Toni Sewell or they'll attack they
attack various people they tend to leave
me alone and I think that that's because
over the years when I was working in
schools I used to know a lot of these
people and they they know that I'm doing
good work they've known me throughout my
career and I'm you know I'm 45 years old
I've been doing this a long time and
they've seen me work with children and
they've seen how committed I've been you
know I'm at school 6:15 6:30 in the
morning every day and I've done this all
my life
you know they've seen the commitment to
the children who they want to see
succeed and I think they give me a bit
of a break actually but I know exactly
what you mean and I
you have people who will attack me I
have to say it's mainly been from the
white left not so much from the black
left and I and I do think that's because
the black left really understand what
I'm doing they get it and they they have
to respect it and they they respect me
all those they probably find some of the
things I say uncomfortable particularly
things you think they find uncomfortable
what you say um is it solely Jasper for
instance is an interesting guy like I
know him and you know we follow each
other on Twitter and you know I I
disagree with much of what he says and
and I often wondered myself actually is
he just muted me on Twitter because how
can he stand to I do I wonder this I
think and I think he just gives me a
pass I think he gives me a pass and why
well and what would upset him it would
upset him that I'm not being more
critical of the right probably that I am
that I like I don't know Michael go for
instance that I you know III don't think
though that he would have a problem with
me saying that children need to be
responsible for themselves I know I've
heard him say this to black kids myself
you know so I've heard and say these
things it's just there's this kind of
war between the right and the left all
the time and what's really sad is that
the left have convinced themselves that
the right only think what they think
because they want to hurt people you
know they want to get rich so they want
to play golf and you know what there are
some right-wingers like okay that's fine
but there are a bunch of people on the
right who want the same things as the
people on the Left they just think that
they're going to get those things
through different methods and if the
left are convinced that's what I mean
about I think the black left or not
don't think I'm evil they don't they
think I'm a good person and they think
that what I'm doing is good and so they
let me get on with it I think too often
on the white left
they just can't process the idea that
that I might be doing good because they
they are very uncomfortable with
some of the things I said you said what
are those things I mean that's what I'm
saying the relationship between effort
and reward the idea that duty to the
team and all of that they the personal
responsibility not making excuses for
kids the idea that we ought to give out
the tensions and that now I'm not like
there's lots of people have left to
think that we should give out detentions
but they'll make excuses for some to not
get that detention um yeah I mean now
you're looking at me like what is it
what is it okay dead white men that's a
big one right dead white men so I
believe that we should be teaching
Shakespeare and I don't know Dickens and
so on um and what people will say people
will often say so this is something I
think Lee Jasper would have to take
issue with me is that unless children
can see themselves in the novel then
they can't identify with it and they're
unable to get as much from it so why are
black children misbehaving it's because
they're having to read about white
characters as opposed to black
characters that might be an argument
that would be put forward and I would
say that life isn't just about race
Shakespeare speaks to everyone in fact a
Maya Angelou you would say that she said
that she when she first read Shakespeare
that she thought that he was a black
woman because there was no way that
anyone could understand the plight of
black women so well in the way that he
did it's universal and you as a person
can transcend you're not just black like
you're all a bunch of different things
you're a person you can read Dickens and
get something out of it whatever color
you are
and it's those its identity politics
where people can only understand you as
well I'm what are you write well I'm a
woman and I'm black and I'm mixed-race
and I'm I don't know whatever but
actually I'm somebody who's a little bit
crazy and I'm I'm a real radical and a
rebel and I and I want to change things
those things that I just said are far
more important actually to Who I am then
me being black and female right so
I just I'm not saying I'm not black
great I'm not saying I'm a female but
but it's it's not all-consuming and um I
think many people on the left are
consumed with that they can't see past
it and I just don't see the world in the
same way well we've got time for a
couple of quick questions the good work
that you do it's obviously you know
there have been times when that's been
difficult for you right and you've
continued to do and you've build this
grade school and I'm sure you will keep
going from strength to strength and we
hope it will but what I'm curious
curious about the personal element of
what is it inside of you people always
say that that makes you want to have
that battle yeah people always say that
it's all those children it's all those
children over the years who I have known
thousands of thousands hundreds of
thousands of children who I've seen not
just still not taught children I've seen
in schools that I visited all around the
world I just from me I can see that
education is the number one thing that
is going to allow them to change their
stars and the reason why I went into
teaching and the reason why I do what I
do is because I want to enable
disadvantaged children to be able to
change their stars you know when I gave
my speech at the Conservative Party
conference and I was told I would never
work in the state sector again I did
consider for about five minutes going to
work in the private sector but then I
thought well I don't want to do that
because the reason why I'm motivated to
wake up in the morning is to change the
chart the lives of these children you
know I'm all for private school and I'm
quite happy that there are private
schools it's just not where I want to
work yeah I don't have a problem with
them they're fine but I want to work
with disadvantaged kids and I want to
change their lives and what is very sad
is that these well-meaning people I say
they're well-meaning but they also want
to be sitting around dinner parties and
feeling happy about themselves are have
created a culture of low expectations
for the children who I teach you know
those tens of thousands of children and
their stories the the many children I
have seen bullied in my life and so on
they're the ones who motivate me because
I just want to reduce the numbers of
them I want every want all children to
be given a chance
of opportunity right that's what I want
well they had the chance right and most
of them do not have the chance and and
that's that's where that's where the
left is right in that sense too many
children are do not have a chance at
equal opportunity but what the left
don't understand is they are the ones
who are taking that chance from them
spoken like a true Nazi all right last
question so what is the thing this is
the thing that we're not talking about
as a society but we really should be
talking about yeah okay I need to think
about that one I mean because there's
loads of things that I just spoke about
that I don't think we're talking about
and we should well I suppose it's the
it's the small see conservative values
that I was referring to before that I
think people on the left and the right
often don't have certainly there are
many big see conservatives who are not
small see conservatives and I know left
wingers who you know often Catholics and
who are very much small see
conservatives and I think people see
small see conservatives as judgmental
and as bad people and actually judgment
isn't always bad and if the more we lose
those values in in in society the more
society crumbles away the reason why the
West has been so successful is because
those values we used to have religion
that brought us together which has
fallen away those values gave us order
and structure because not just children
who need order and structure society
needs it too and when you have a
free-for-all where everybody just gets
to do what they want and everybody can
just argument to be me and I have to
discover me and so on and and they have
no sense of duty and obligation they
have no sense of how they can give to
others you know throughout life that's
what I'm doing I'm doing something with
my life so that I can pass the baton on
at the end it's what gives your life
meaning it's what gives it is what holds
a society together and sadly I think
we've lost that well Katherine Berg will
sink the dragon lady thank you very much
for coming on trigonometry you're on
Twitter at yes at miss underscore Snuffy
which I have to explain because that's a
bit odd for a headmistress it's nothing
being SN USF why because when I used to
write a blog called to miss with love I
was Miss snuffleupagus
the big mammoth elephant in Sesame
Street who could never be seen so the
elephant in the room and eventually it
got shortened to miss Snuffy well so
follow Katherine on Twitter she's always
posting great and very interesting stuff
I follow her with great interest as
always follow us at trigger pod on
Twitter Instagram and Facebook and
subscribe to us on YouTube click that
Bell button next to subscribe button and
as Francis always says do give us a
review on iTunes we've got like 40 now
we can use a few more and that's it
thank you very much for tuning in we
will see you in the week from now with
another brilliant episode take care guys
thank you very much bye bye
[Music]